find the coordinates of all points on
the curve at which the line tangent to
the curve at that point
is vertical so we want to figure out the
points on that curve where the tangent
line is vertical so let's just remind
ourselves what a what a what the slope
of a tangent line is or or what it isn't
i guess this may be a better way to
think about it if you have a horizontal
line so let me draw a horizontal line if
you have a horizontal line like that
well then your slope is zero or you
could say your rate of change of y with
respect to x is equal to zero
but what about a vertical line if you
have a vertical line like that
what is your rate of change of y with
respect to x well some people might say
it's infinity or you could say it's
undefined
it's
undefined in some way because at some
point or one way to think about you're
gonna you're gonna try to divide by zero
because you have a huge change in y over
no change in x or another way to think
about it that's a little bit more in
line with that is you could say that
your change in x with respect to change
in y notice i took the reciprocal so now
we're talking about our change in the
derivative of x with respect to y
is equal to zero because your y can
change but as your y changes your x does
not change
so can we use this little insight here
on vertical lines to think about the
coordinates of all points on the curve
at which the line tangent to the curve
at that point is vertical
well before they told us
they gave us the curve of the equation
and they also told us what dydx is let
me just rewrite them again just so we
have them there so we know that
y to the third minus x y is equal to two
this is the equation of our curve and we
know that d y
d x is equal to y
over
3 y squared minus x
so
one thing that we could do is well let's
just figure out what d the derivative of
x with respect to y is and set that to
be equal to 0. so this is the derivative
of y with respect to x if we take the
reciprocal of that the derivative of x
with respect to y just the reciprocal of
this is going to be the reciprocal of
what we have here so it's going to be
so it's going to be 3
y squared minus x
over y
and if we want this to be equal to 0
like we said right over here well then
that's only going to happen if the
numerator is equal to 0. so we can say
okay at what xy pair does this numerator
equal to 0. 3y squared minus x is equal
to 0. you can add x to both sides and
you get 3 y squared is equal to x
another way you could have thought about
it is what what at what x and y values
does the derivative of y with respect to
x become undefined well that's going to
become undefined if the denominator here
is zero but when you're dealing with
things like undefined it gets a little
bit it gets a little bit more more hand
wave yeah i like to just think of this
is the rate at which x is changing with
respect to y
is zero and so that got us to the same
conclusion well for for that to be true
x has to be equal to three y squared and
of course the xy pair has to also
satisfy the equation for the curve
so why don't we use both of these
constraints and then we can solve for x
and y
and so the easiest thing i can do i can
think of doing is let's substitute x
with 3y squared because they are the
same that's the second constraint so if
we take our original equation of the
curve we get y to the third minus
instead of writing x i could write 3y
squared
3y squared times y
times y is equal to two
and so we get
y to the third minus three y to the
third is equal to two
this is negative two
y to the third is equal to two we can
divide both sides by
negative two and we get
we get y to the third is equal to
negative one or y is equal to negative
one negative one to the third power is
negative 1. now if y is negative 1 what
is x
well x is going to be equal to 3
times
negative 1
squared
so negative 1 squared is just 1 so x is
going to be equal to three so the point
on that curve at which the tangent line
is vertical
is going to be the point three comma
negative one
and we are all done